with major blockbusters and tentpole
franchises taking up most of our
attention these days it can be easy to
lose track of all the great movies
sneaking under the radar but these 2018
fantasy movies are well worth seeking
out annihilation based on the first book
in Jeff van der Meers the southern reach
trilogy annihilation marks Alex
Garland's second outing as a director
after his successful debut with 2015's
ex machina and he's delivered once again
the story is told from the perspective
of Lina an army vet and cellular biology
professor she joins an intrepid band of
women as they enter the shimmer a
mysterious area in the swamplands of
Florida where some abnormal activity has
been taking place after a recent meteor
strike Lina's primary goal is to find
out what happened to her husband Kane
the comatose lone survivor of a doomed
expedition into the shimmer as the team
pushes on into the heart of the shimmer
strange things begin to unfold and
evolve as the group finds themselves
fighting against the environment each
other and even themselves you're saying
that we cut out by going deeper in yeah
if you like
no I don't like annihilation is a
fascinating workout for the imagination
simultaneously pushing the viewer to
freakish levels of stress and wonder I
kill Giants using the imagination to
escape the pain of reality is a common
theme in childhood stories which makes
Anders Walters I killed is even more of
a gem in his smashing feature
directorial debut Walter has
successfully brought Joe Kelly's graphic
novel to life offering viewers a
mesmerizing tale of heartache and
adventure Barbara Thorson is a restless
12-year old girl living on Long Island
where she's an outcast at school in
spite of attempts made by her school
counselor to reach out to her but rather
than bury herself in video games or
books she takes on a different hobby
Giants Lane the film beautifully weaves
together childhood sorrow and thrilling
escapism along with an epic dose of
fantastical action with solid directing
acting and CGI this all-around high
quality feature has a kind of Pan's
Labyrinth feel to it and is sure to
appeal to the giant slayer inside you
the endless blockbusters can be fun and
full of eye candy but there's always
something extra special about a
well-made movie that didn't have access
to a gargantuan budget case in point
Justin Benson and Aaron Moore heads the
endless and not quite sequel to 2012's
resolution Benson and more head directed
shot and starred in the endless joining
forces to deliver a shocking fantasy tin
story of cultish fear to disturb even
the most stalwart horror fan the film's
storyline follows Justin and Aaron Smith
as they wearily return to the death cult
they'd once escaped once there the
seemingly unnatural peace is slowly and
masterfully broken down in a series of
Revelations that expose all of crafty
and underbelly of horror it shows us
what it seems
as a powerful elegance Tastefully
terrorizing this film blends elements of
fantasy sci-fi and horror all without
relying on an inflated budget or a-list
actors neither of which topped the
endless from attracting near Universal
critical acclaim
psychokinesis how do you think you gain
telekinetic powers well by drinking
water from a mountain spring hit by a
meteor of course at least that's what
train to busan's director's saying
hoyeon had in mind when he made one of
the most refreshingly unusual superhero
movies of the year written and directed
by yeon psychokinesis is a good reminder
that superhero movies don't always have
to be about saving the world
the story is inwardly focused following
the origin of the unlikely hero so kyun
who accidentally gains telekinetic
powers it's all just in time to receive
a distress call from his estranged
daughter roomie informing him that an
aggressive mob run construction company
is threatening her trendy fried chicken
restaurant and sold launched into the
action as he's still just beginning to
understand and control his own abilities
so kyon comes across as a perfectly
illegitimate superhero frustrated by his
own powers and often unable to think on
his feet simple and refreshingly light
it's a superhero movie of down-to-earth
proportions and a welcome change of pace
in the Marvel and DC dominated world
[Music]
the man who killed Don Quixote before
the turn of the Millenium director Terry
Gilliam set out to film an adaptation of
miguel de cervantes classic 1615 novel
don quixote his pursuit of that goal
became the stuff of Hollywood legend of
Gilliam battled through a seemingly
endless series of production delays cast
turnovers and legal and financial
Fiasco's it even inspired its own
documentary 2002's lost in La Mancha
which followed the futility of an early
attempt that included Johnny Depp Casto
Sancho Panza but Gilliam's vision for
his comically romanticized film was set
with gritty determination and literally
decades later the movie has finally
arrived in the form of the man who
killed Don Quixote the film plot
progresses through an absurd and
fantastic series of events with Adam
driver playing a simple yet perfect foil
to Jonathan prices wide-eyed ludicrously
charming shoemaker who believes he is
the real Don Quixote it's a fun movie
with a great story behind it which only
serves to make it that much more
interesting to watch
[Music]